shannon is with us in kansas hey Shannon
your question for Chris Hogan and me um
yes I was recently sued for about
300,000 I do have a traditional IRA and
I was just wondering if it would be
smart to cash that in and pay off the
lawsuit and then start rebuilding it it
is my only day so you're not only sued
you lost
um well we split it half she sued me for
a lot more
so you have a current debt to this
person of 300 grand yes woo ouch okay
how much is in your IRA about 750 okay
and you're how old
um almost 50 okay so this is going to
cost you ten percent plus your tax rate
what's your household income well we're
in real estate so it varies I know but
what is your taxable income in the
coming year approximately about two
hundred and fifty thousand okay so
you're in a forty percent tax bracket so
thirty eight percent so you're gonna
lose that plus ten percent you're gonna
lose forty eight percent of this money
that you pull out to the government
before you get the money so you're going
to clean the whole 750 out to pay the
three hundred almost okay so not a smart
move not less not if you got anyplace
else you can get it where else do you
have we are debt free I'm not taking out
a loan to pay this off I agree with that
Oh what do you do on a rental property
that's paid for 51 of them 51 of them
okay
let's sell let's sell enough of one of
those or a couple of those and pay
with that it's going to cost you a whole
lot less okay I brought I'm with you I
like real estate too but that you don't
have you're not going to get hit in the
jaw for 40% when you cash out a rental
property or two to pay this deal off
okay how fresh is the settlement it has
to be paid by September of next year
okay all right that's perfect to build
put a piece of property or new on the
market get it sold right correct out of
the 51 there's a couple of them you
don't like that much anyway about three
that will add up to mysteriously 300
grand yeah I would do that because your
worst case is you have no capital gains
on one or two of those based on your
adjusted basis you know how to do that
formula and you know it's all gonna it's
still gonna be a bazillion dollars less
than 40 or 8% which is what you're
facing the other way yeah that's that's
rough ouch you know it is and one of the
things you could see her trying to
process but as you laid that out and
helped her to understand you're gonna
surrender 48 percent of it and so that
math becomes easy now and yeah like you
said Dave you list those properties
those three get this thing paid out of
your life and then guess what you're a
real estate agent you'll have a cap on
your income so you get I carry launder
and you Megan do I get it backed up to
three hundred thousand a year and buy
your properties back with cash yeah yeah
she's probably got a bunch of them yes
yes I'm guessing so yeah three hundred
thousand sounds really bad to your 51
properties in seminary fifty thousand in
the 401k so I think it can probably limp
through this but still bad yes no no day
you write that check is a good day
you've got a ouch